6 25 your black friday morning what's  cool at school being thankful  some encouraging words from governor  steve sisilak and then youngsters from  cc ronald elementary busted out their  singing skills to show them they got the  message we need to be thankful for the  people that we have around us because  we're really  really lucky when you think about it  [Music]  [Music]  oh great job kids also the governor as  you saw there the nevada national guard  they were honoring rono's principal  michelle crawford with an air force  commendation medal if you know something  that's cool at school let us know cool  at school we're under the community tab  on our website eightnewsnow.com or just  send us an email coolandschool  8newsnow.com